flawless my dear
gossip girls set in the 19th century
with gorgeous ball gowns and
scandalous romances this is exactly the
kind of netflix content we needed to get
through the winter
i wish to be entertained if you haven't
watched bridgeton yet you'll probably
want to binge it before diving into this
video so we don't spoil any of the drama
bridgeton was a huge risk for netflix
filming on the series started in july
2019 and wrapped in february 2020
just before the pandemic hit that's
almost nine months of shooting which is
pretty long for a tv show
combine that with the incredible sets
and literally thousands of costumes and
the drama-filled 19th century romance
could have easily been a disaster
thankfully shonda rhimes was behind the
breathtaking tv series and here is how
the huge undertaking all came together
behind the scenes like gossip girl
bridgerton gets its inspiration from a
book series
it was inspired by julia quinn's
best-selling novels
the first of which is fittingly titled
the duke and i
quinn is incredibly popular with about
10 million books in print in the us
alone when approached with the idea for
the show she
jumped at the chance to give shonda
creative control of the series
she read the script as a consultant but
wasn't involved in the writing
as for shonda she knew immediately after
reading the series that she wanted to
turn the burning hot romance into her
next big television event
the thing about romance novels is they
don't get taken very seriously
but by providing a luck series with
intriguing character depth
shonda is bringing the steamy romance to
the forefront of entertainment
but you might be surprised to know that
shonda wasn't the official creator
or showrunner of the series she passed
that torch over to chris van dusen
who previously worked with her on grey's
anatomy and scandal
the bridgerton books follow the eight
alphabetically named bridgeton siblings
while the concepts stayed relatively the
same there were a few changes made to
make the series more modern
for one shonda wanted a 21st century
audience to see themselves in these
characters
so diversity was very important
particularly in casting a black
queen charlotte and though the series
and show are set in the regency era
neither the show's creators nor quinn
were very concerned with historical
accuracy
they wanted to avoid the typical
historical romance tropes
which meant giving their female
characters agency despite them having to
try and conform to 19th century society
but even if perfect historical accuracy
wasn't the main concern
transporting the audience to the 1800s
definitely
was in order to get the actors fully
immersed in the regency romance
the cast spent six weeks in a boot camp
getting familiar with things like
horseback riding
regency history etiquette and dancing
this is where the cast learned more
about their characters like how the
featherington sisters are meant to be
like the kardashians of the 19th century
while the bridgertons are more like the
kennedys you know
new money versus old money penelope is
kind of like the chloe of the family
while lady portia featherington is a
kris jenner like
momager with a six-week boot camp
followed by more than
six months of filming it's no surprise
that the cast are now
incredibly close phoebe denver who plays
daphne
thinks of jonathan bailey who plays
anthony as an older brother
and claudia jesse who plays eloise is
now best friends with nicola cochlin
who plays penelope some other
interesting secrets from the stars
are that nicola cochlin was working in a
doctor's office before she landed her
role
golda rocheval didn't originally
audition for the role of queen charlotte
but for another unspecified role that
she didn't get
and jonathan bailey was on his way to
coachella when he heard the news that he
would be
lord anthony bridgerton as for being
starstruck
the entire cast did freak out about one
cast member
though they didn't even get to film
scenes with her the true scene stealer
even though she doesn't actually appear
on camera was the one and only
julie andrews who voices lady whistle
down
now you're not the only one who's
wondering what it's like for the
bridgerton stars to film those steamy
love scenes into the bedroom
but surprisingly they're not nearly as
awkward as we thought they would be
you might have noticed that daphne's
romantic scenes with simon are almost
entirely shot from her perspective
to give the show a more feminist lens as
for phoebe
and reggie champage's on-set chemistry
phoebe said the extensive preparation
ahead of filming played a large part
they actually worked with a coordinator
to help develop a behind-the-scenes
relationship with one another that would
translate well on screen
so when it came to that scene in episode
6 where daphne and simon get hot and
heavy in the library
they weren't too nervous which is good
considering that was actually the first
scene the pair
ever filmed together all of the most
romantic scenes are a huge deal to the
film
and are completely choreographed they
take at least half a day to shoot
and while the actors were all exhausted
by the end they never
once felt uncomfortable while bridgerton
is probably not the kind of show you'd
want to watch with your parents the
stars managed not to be too embarrassed
by their families watching
i think the most horrifying thing is
when your parents aren't horrified
like you're sitting there and you're
like oh phoebe admitted she warned hers
and had to make sure to distance herself
from the character of daphne so she
wouldn't feel too
embarrassed while reggae joked that he
would rather keep it a surprise
as for the real challenging scenes
though they had nothing to do with
romance
the most difficult ones were actually
those involving horses me and people
particularly were very
happy and confident with our horses
until they said action
for those working behind the scenes
creating the costumes was
incredibly difficult the show has 7
500 outfits over eight episodes and it
took five months to make them all
ellen mirage nick was the show's costume
designer and you might know her work
from the greatest showmen
daphne alone wears 93 dresses throughout
the first season
to create unique looks for the
characters that blend modern and regency
era fashion
the designer created mood boards and
used the cut and color of clothing to
distinguish the sophisticated bridgetons
from the more superficial featheringtons
mirage neck also used a lot of
embellishments to liven up the costumes
and you'll notice a lot of layered
jewelry tulle and lace
they had a whole team in charge of
finding the perfect embellishments to
make these costumes
perfectly over the top this also meant
that each look was incredibly
complicated
especially queen charlotte's she has a
different wig and dress in
every scene and sometimes she was even
wearing two wigs to appear even more
flamboyant and exaggerated
these looks often included things like
feathers and pearls and
tons of petticoats it took half an hour
to put on the queen's costumes
and it took two people to help her get
in and out of those double corseted
outfits
and speaking of corsets the ones for the
series were designed by
an icon mr pearl he's the best corset
designer in the business and has done
looks for beyonce
madonna and the kardashians
another aspect that took as much work as
costuming was choreography
the dances were so intricate and
specifically tailored to each character
thanks to choreographer jack murphy the
dances intertwined modern movement and
time period appropriate style
the dancing was actually the part that
made phoebe denver the most nervous
since she says she was never much of a
dancer thankfully the choreographer had
their backs
and it ended up being a great bonding
experience for the entire cast
creating those massive ballroom scenes
was a huge challenge for the set design
crew as well there were around 200
people working behind the scenes to make
everything look
perfect but it was pretty hard
transforming modern mansions into 19th
century homes
one of the carpenters on set reportedly
dedicated four months
just to making time-appropriate
fireplaces and windows
so those are all the details behind
season one but
what about season two will there be one
and what will it be like
well there's no confirmation yet but
showrunner chris van dusen is definitely
up for a second season
since there are eight siblings each of
whose story is central to different
novels in quinn's series
making more seasons is definitely in the
cards it seems even more likely thanks
to a recent listing from production
weekly
which shows that season 2 is set to
start filming in uxbridge england in
march 2021
the next book in the series is titled
the vi count who loved me
and focuses on anthony's love story so
if we do get a second season of this new
drama we're all obsessed with we can
probably expect to see a lot more of
anthony
and definitely another look at daphne
and the dukes blossoming life together
would you like to see eight different
seasons each focusing on a different
bridgerton
let us know in the comments down below
don't forget to hit that like button if
you enjoyed this video and subscribe for
more
thanks for watching